un mélange de curling et de pétanque
découverte à présent d'un loisir qui se
pratique habituellement sur les ponts
des paquebots de croisière heureusement
pour les besoins du tournage nous
n'avons pas eu besoin de réserver une
cabine sur un bateau mais on vous emmène
simplement ce soir du côté de Tours Nord
à la découverte donc du shuffle board
une activité qui peut aussi se pratiquer
sur la terre ferme Clémence dose qui a
testé pour nous la seule piste de la
région
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des palais un terrain et des cannes pour
les faire glisser aujourd'hui
téléthurbate de Loire test pour vous le
shuffleboard nous sommes à Tours Nord au
shuffle Factory ou Pierre nous attend il
va falloir que j'aille m'équiper
l'entraînement va commencer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on dirait un peu des trucs de diablotin
[Musique]
l'idée voilà c'est de mettre un maximum
de palets dans les zones de points
puisqu'à la fin de la manche on va
compter tous les points il faut aussi
être bien précis puisque voilà le palais
il faut qu'il soit parfaitement dans la
zone de points et pas toucher les lignes
c'est challengeant parce que du coup une
partie est jamais gagnée jamais perdue
avec ce petit côté on peut prendre des
points mais aussi on peut aussi les
perdre la case -10 peut tout faire
basculer par maladresse en y mettant son
propre palais ou façon pétanque en y
poussant ceux des adversaires
[Musique]
ouais donc là on est à -30 à peu près ça
va
les seules pistes de shuffleboard sont
ici à Tours car comme son nom le laisse
entendre la discipline est anglo-saxonne
en fait qui cherchait à mettre un jeu
sur le pont des bateaux et donc ça s'est
développé États-Unis Canada et nous on a
découvert ça lors d'un voyage à Londres
donc on trouvait ça super chouette
c'était à l'heure de l'After Work il y
avait vraiment plein de gens les gens
partagent le jeu
[Musique]
voilà donc là j'ai zéro en équipe et à
tout âge le shuffleboard est une
discipline relativement simple à prendre
en main ici il y a 6 terrains qu'on peut
réserver c'est à partir de 35 euros le
terrain pour environ une heure deux
parties de mon côté la performance n'est
pas vraiment au rendez-vous je vais
retourner m'entraîner pour devenir une
compétitrice hors pair
[Musique]